Type the word "define" and the word you want to know.
You don't even have to click anything.
There's the definition as you type.
It's also a complete FAA database.
Type the name of the airline and the flight.
It shows you where the flight is, the gate, the terminal,
how long until it lands.
You don't need an app.
It's also unit and currency conversion.
Again, you don't have to click one of the results.
Just type it into the box, and there's your answer.
While we're talking about text --
When you want to highlight --
this is just an example --
(Laughter)
When you want to highlight a word,
please don't waste your life dragging across it
with the mouse like a newbie.
Double click the word.
Watch "200" -- I go double-click,
it neatly selects just that word.
Also, don't delete what you've highlighted.
You can just type over it.
This is in every program.
Also, you can go double-click, drag,
to highlight in one-word increments as you drag.
Much more precise.
Again, don't bother deleting.
Just type over it.
(Laughter)
Shutter lag is the time between your pressing the shutter button
and the moment the camera actually snaps.
It's extremely frustrating on any camera under $1,000.
(Camera click)
(Laughter)
So, that's because the camera needs time to calculate the focus and exposure,
but if you pre-focus with a half-press,
leave your finger down --
no shutter lag!
You get it every time.
I've just turned your $50 camera into a $1,000 camera with that trick.
And finally, it often happens that you're giving a talk,
and for some reason, the audience is looking at the slide
instead of at you!
(Laughter)
So when that happens -- this works in Keynote, PowerPoint,
it works in every program -- all you do is hit the letter B key,
B for blackout, to black out the slide, make everybody look at you,
and then when you're ready to go on, you hit B again,
and if you're really on a roll, you can hit the W key for "whiteout,"
and you white out the slide,
and then you can hit W again to un-blank it.
So I know I went super fast.
If you missed anything, I'll be happy to send you the list of these tips.
In the meantime, congratulations.
You all get your California Technology License.
Have a great day.
(Applause)